[Music]
foreign
Africa was hit especially hard by the
covid-19 pandemic
across most of the continent Health
measures were insufficient many African
countries received vaccines late and in
meager quantities
how did people there cope and what
Solutions did they find
that's what we're highlighting in this
week's edition of the covid-19 Special
Report welcome
but first we take a look at India where
Health Department employees are getting
ready to roll out a nasal vaccine the
aim is to make vaccine injections a
thing of the past
this vaccination Center in New Delhi can
immunize up to 300 people a day
but doctors say lately only a few people
show up daily
today Dr Richa Gautam who heads the
center says that they expect that to
change soon foreign
she thinks the newly developed nasal
vaccine will increase the number of
vaccinations at the center
vaccine is to be a
to be a spray or aerosol forms this will
not require any injection technique
which is invasive in the logistic part
also we don't need to maintain all the
biomedical waste terms like half cutter
and the syringes and needles which will
be curved down with the introduction of
this vaccine like this Center many other
vaccination facilities in India are also
awaiting their first batch of nasal
vaccines
a few kilometers away this Hospital in
Delhi regularly carries out vaccination
trials
Dr anupam such Deva a vaccine expert
says the newly developed nasal vaccine
could be a game changer in curbing kovid
covered intranasal vaccine will make
sure that there are border guards in the
nose so your infiltration that sarskop
19 will be neutralized at the border
itself
it will not be allowed to enter the body
India is known as the world's largest
vaccine manufacturer
with the recent development of a nasal
vaccine by the Homegrown company bharth
biotech
the country hopes that the new delivery
system will become a long-term solution
to respiratory infection
concerned with the dip in vaccination
numbers Dr sunila Garg who heads the
government appointed covet task posts
is confident that the nasal vaccine can
help in Mass immunization campaigns and
fight vaccine hesitancy we are
privileged that India is the first
country to have the nasal vaccine and
it's a historic moment we still have you
know a huge population across different
continents which is yet to be humanized
so that's where it can play a very very
critical role in Faster immunization as
the world continues to witness sporadic
surges of the code 19 virus
several other countries are developing
nasal vaccines with some of them in
their final trial phases
but India is one of the few countries
which has already approved its emergency
use to curb code 19.
at the outset of the covid-19 pandemic
many countries struggled to carry out
enough PCR tests in such a short time
they couldn't tell who had the virus and
might pass it on
but scientists in the West African
country of Ghana used the strategy of
pool testing it's caught on worldwide
[Music]
team of virologists at work at this
biomedical lab in Ghana's Capital Accra
virologist William ampofo heads the team
that's based at the University of
Ghana's naguchi Memorial Institute for
medical research
here he and his colleagues spent hours
testing samples at the start of the
pandemic
so for covid-19 we take respiratory
samples we go to the other labs we
extract the RNA then we add reagents
to be able to amplify the RNA of the SAS
Cove 2 and then we come and put it in
this thermal cyclist and then you run
for about an hour and a half two hours
and then we're able to have a clear
indication by looking at graphs that are
produced because the material is
Amplified during the process so we call
this real-time
PCR polymerase chain reaction
when kovid first came to Ghana the
country struggled to produce test
results quickly
it lacked adequate infrastructure and
staff and that only heightened people's
anxiety
so ampofo and his team procured
Logistics and reagents to set up their
lab and start testing
they used a pooling system which enabled
them to test some 10 000 samples a day
so they put testing principle is very
simple if you have 10 samples
okay and then you take a little bit of
each of each sample and then you put
into one two so you test this one to you
when you test this tube and it's
negative then it means all the 10
samples are negative
okay but if you test this one sample
this one that has all all the 10 pools
in it if you test this one and it is
positive then that means that one of the
ten is positive so you have to find out
which one so you have to unpoo
approach May Garner one of the African
countries that carried out the most
tests per 100 000 people
it helped Garners covid-19 response team
to better understand the spread of the
disease and adapt their strategies
accordingly
saving many lives
and that's attracted the attention of
other scientists
it's interesting at the end of the day
even our colleagues from Europe and
Northern countries started
implementing the pooling system and so
for me we can't feel anything but to
feel good because we showed leadership
we showed Direction and I think that is
what noguchi is about
young scientists here are inspired by
the opportunity to work with ampopho and
learn how to combat kovid
you know this pandemic has been so so
serious it has taken like a lot of lives
knowing that you are partaking and like
a very vital role in producing results
testing to save lives
I might say that it has been a really
massive response to this pandemic
lessons drawn from fighting covid-19 are
also helping ampofo and his team deal
with other deadly viruses
we're very happy that we Rose to the
challenge we're very happy that we
continue to provide uh support to the
Ghana Health Service and ministerial
Health not just for covid-19 but when we
had cases of monkey pox when we had
Marburg virus detected
William ampofo and his colleagues are
determined to play their part in helping
Ghana win the fight against covet 19.
even as the covid-19 Delta variant was
killing tens of thousands in her home
country South Africa zanele never
thought she'd be affected
but after catching covid she ended up in
hospital
luckily her husband stayed healthy and
took care of her while working during
the entire pandemic that's how they
escaped The Economic Consequences that
drove many of their compatriots to ruin
a new episode in our my covet series
we didn't know what was going to happen
we didn't know how many people were
going to pass away we didn't know who
was going to pass away we didn't know if
we were going to be alive
my name is zanele
I live in Johannesburg and I had covert
19. I was inflicted with covid-19 in
June 2021 my symptoms were the normal
flu symptoms
but I rapidly deteriorated I started to
feel breathless I tried to get a
hospital I couldn't get into a hospital
in Johannesburg the hospitals were fully
booked I had to be taken by ambulance to
a neighboring Hospital in Pretoria and I
was admitted for a week
I didn't talk too much to my doctor
because I was very nervous and the
clinic itself was very busy
my actual covert symptoms lasted for six
months
however I still experienced some
symptoms like tiredness
um memory loss
we lost people we watched television and
lost so many friends and family so it
was
um a very bitter and difficult time
but for me it was also nice that I could
be at home with my husband and just
reconnect in order to protect myself
against covert today I make sure that I
eat uh very well I have a balanced diet
I have my breakfast my lunch my supper I
include a lot of Greens in my diet I
also exercise by walking
when I got covert I was not vaccinated
and the reason for that is because of
the negative publicity about the
vaccinations but my experience of being
hospitalized was an eye-opener I decided
to get vaccinated just to avoid having
you know another experience
foreign
[Music]
just like in the rest of the world many
people there complain of ongoing
symptoms known as long covert in
addition to the physical effects the
psychological consequences are also
becoming clear it can even lead to a
permanent inability to work
simple tasks like getting out of bed in
the morning have become a challenge for
Yvonne chengue
not long after my covid-19 infection
which was last year June
I developed a excruciating pain under my
feet which made it difficult for me to
walk and to stand for long periods of
time
immediately after that I started
developing some anxiety and depression
a single mother and business owner
chengue was forced to shut down her shop
during South Africa's covered block down
one of the strictests in the world as a
massage therapist her profession
requires her to be on her feet all day
long but her lingering symptoms have
made it impossible for her to return to
work
after losing my business and my income
it was very hard
I had to give up my rental apartment to
move in with my partner in order to save
some money
and since there's this uncertainty of
not knowing when I'll be able to resume
my practice I decided to enroll for a
course teaching English as a second
language online
Yvonne chengue is not alone more than 4
million South Africans have so far
tested positive for covid-19 and at
least 10 percent of them will develop
longer term symptoms according to the
country's National Institute for
communicable diseases
thank you
that means at least 400 000 people still
battling with covert related symptoms
six months or more after their initial
diagnosis
Samantha Encore is one of them
I was in hospital for a total of 10
weeks six of those in ICU I struggled
with short of breath issues also
cognition and memory issues
her symptoms continued for 11 months
during this time she was unable to work
so she registered for temporary
disability assistance luckily she has
health insurance and was referred to a
private Rehabilitation Center in
Johannesburg okay that's fine we offer a
holistic client-centered approach for
long-covered patients we offer
occupational therapy Physiotherapy and
speech therapy for those patients
we've seen an increase in referrals of
people who've had long covert and who
are struggling months down the line
Samantha Encore has gone from being on
oxygen 24 7 to being able to return to
work full-time
changed my life my memory is better my
cognition issues are gone and I'm just a
different person now
rehab matters is one of a handful of
facilities in South Africa treating long
covet it's a private practice and caters
to people who either have health
insurance or can afford to pay out of
pocket altogether just 27 percent of the
population
for the other 40 million plus South
Africans who rely on Public Health Care
like Yvonne chengue treatment options
are limited
wide variety of symptoms that can
include pain other physical weakness and
even memory for people who do not have
access to private rehab facilities
there's only one government-funded
facility however that is in Cape Town so
most of the cases are going untreated
but Cape Town is a long way from
Johannesburg where Yvonne chengue lives
she eventually found relief through
acupuncture
a form of alternative therapy that is
practiced in Chinese medicine regarded
by some as a pseudoscience its medical
credibility is disputed but for Yvonne
it's making a difference without
breaking the bank
it's my second time here and I opted for
this after being told by Western doctors
that they could not do anything for the
pain in my feet that I developed after
my covet and the the reason was that
there's lots of people who are
presenting with different core problems
after covet and so they just write it
down to Long covet and there's nothing
really they can do at the moment and I
came here and the pain in my feet has
eased a lot and I feel there is hope
okay how you feel I feel so much better
thank you okay so the doctor right now
give you two type of the medication to
use this one it's to drink yeah it will
help you to release the pain and for the
circulations while she is still on the
road to recovery she's optimistic that
she'll soon be able to reopen her
business and return to normal life
why do some people get really sick from
the coronavirus even though they're
young fit and healthy that's not really
clear yet
but one answer might lie in a person's
genes
researchers from the Berlin Institute of
Health at Berlin's Charity Hospital have
presented a new study our colleague
Christina kufner talked to Dr Mike
pizzner about it
what exactly predisposes people to
severe infection
so clinicians noted early on that severe
covid-19 occurs more often than older
people or in male people and
particularly in those who are overweight
but also in those who come with multiple
pre-existing conditions like type 2
diabetes or cardiovascular diseases
however we do see these severe covid-19
cases also among apparently healthy
subjects of patients which means there
must be something else to it and early
studies show that in patients with rare
um
mutations and genes that are responsible
for the immune system they were more
often affected fossil severe covert 19.
how much influence do our genes actually
have in brief it's supposed to be modest
is the first thing you need to
understand is that genes aren't active
elements genes are blueprints for what
is called proteins and proteins are the
ones who actually do the action who
facilitate life and
enable us to react to a viral infection
um and what other Studies have
identified are regions in the genome
that code for those proteins related to
the immune system or to lung function
and if this varies so the blueprint
varies a bit doesn't it need to be a
major variation but very tiny very
common ones
um puts you at a higher risk for
covid-19 or severe covid-19 in
particular
in collaboration with other researchers
your group just published a new study on
this issue what is it about
so what we saw is there are about eight
proteins that seem to have a role either
in as a predisposing into a more severe
covid-19 outcome but also to have seem
to have a protective role so we have for
instance identified a protein called
elf5
which is expressed in specific lung
cells that are also the target of the
virus
and if you have more of this protein in
your cells you're more likely to develop
severe covert 19.
um and then on the other hand we
identified proteins like gcsf
um which have a role in the immune
response and patients who have higher
levels of this protein seem to be a bit
more protected
um against severe covered 19. so given
the knowledge available can we translate
it into better treatment strategies
so I think our study
contributes a small piece to a larger
puzzle so so what we identify is some
some basic knowledge like either five
and how this may relate to the wound
repair upon infection in the lung which
isn't quite clear yet
and I find it quite exciting to at least
name some potential drug targets because
it's really difficult to develop drugs
anyway so it usually takes decades and
now we need to do this within like
months or only a couple of years and I
think by bringing together all these
different
um data we might highlight some some new
uh candidate proteins that my people are
following up
Dr Pizza thank you for talking to us
thank you bye
in the Ivory Coast keeping track of
medical records is a real problem files
often get lost and have to be recreated
making monitoring developments over time
nearly impossible a clinic in the city
of doku has decided to try out an
Innovative patient-centered approach
foreign
the large doku Clinic has decided to
test a new solution
they're using a new electronic health
booklet
this is the Musso Health pass it's a
small bracelet containing a person's
health history the clinic adopted this
device in 2020 during the covid-19
pandemic to deal with any emergencies
there are patients who come who are
unconscious if they have the electronic
bracelet we have all their information
in one click
there are also patients who come in who
can't speak French
this type of patient can give us the
information via the Musso pass
the bracelet was invented here
in 2014 entrepreneur Korean watchera
decided to launch her idea using the
profits from her textile Workshop
since then a team of developers has been
stationed right next to the sewing
machines
due to the covid-19 pandemic and the
need for new e-health Solutions there's
been renewed interest in the Musso pass
during the Health crisis people
understood that barriers have to be
broken down
which means that distances in care
should no longer exist we need to use
e-health teleconsultation tele expertise
and Home Care
foreign
to ensure that the health records are
secure the team has put several levels
of security in place they also receive a
message as soon as their personal
information is accessed
as soon as someone logs onto the
interface to see your information you
get a message like this one
then access to the platform to the
server and the team gets renewed
we're 100 dedicated to working on all
aspects of the platform's data security
today corinthara would like her solution
to be deployed throughout the Ivory
Coast thanks to a partnership with the
Ivory Coast post office she's traveling
across the country to raise awareness
about the past the first stop is seguela
a town in the northwest of the country
the aim is to campaign there and
convince 200 women to adopt the Musso
pass you see what I have in my hand here
is a bracelet that I wear but it's not a
normal bracelet it's my health book it
means that all my information is in it
so why is that because if I leave here I
could have an accident and if the
doctors want to help me they need to
know that I'm asthmatic I have sinusitis
and a history of epilepsy
at four Euros 50 for the bracelet and
three Euros for the card the prices are
simply too expensive for many who live
here but today is the only opportunity
to get this nationally accepted Health
ID
if you're in a small village and have a
problem the doctors there can save you
quickly that means your life is always
safe
but when you don't have a health ID it's
really not good
Corinne's speech was convincing and
bears fruit
[Music]
the enthusiasm was so great that the
Musso Health pass teams were quickly
overwhelmed
says do you know your blood type what is
it a positive a total of 350 people were
enrolled that day
Korean feels reassured because even
though covid-19 infections have slowed
down in the country the past could help
in dealing with any new waves
if the crisis comes back we'll be asked
which people have been infected in the
past
they will ask for a history of the
patients and that's also important with
the past because it traces everything
have I ever been infected with covid
am I a person who is susceptible to the
disease
even though there are now just under 82
000 positive cases in the country
Corinne wants to remain mobilized
her trip will continue to four more
cities
that was this we
this report focusing on African
countries
see you next week until then bye bye and
stay healthy
[Music]